europe's massive problem of youth
unemployment tops the agenda this week
as ministers responsible for employment
social policy health and consumer
affairs meet in luxembourg
with eu leaders set next week to focus
on ways to get young people into jobs
the ministers will discuss efforts to
implement a youth guarantee scheme seen
as a top eu employment priority
on average across the 27 eu nations
almost one in four people under 25 were
out of work in april
the youth guarantee aims to ensure that
young people like them receive a quality
job offer further education an
apprenticeship or traineeship within
four months of leaving school or
becoming unemployed
youth unemployment will also be in the
spotlight as the ministers try to agree
a general approach on the european
globalization adjustment fund the egf so
that negotiations can begin with
european parliament the fund was set up
in response to the economic crisis and
helps workers who lost their jobs due to
the recession and globalization to find
new employment and develop new skills
the ministers will debate the scope of
the fund ways to finance it categories
of people who might be eligible and
support for youth employment
the conditions of those most in need
will also be on the agenda as the
council hears a progress report on the
fund for european aid to the most
deprived
eu leaders confirmed in february that
2.5 billion euros would be earmarked for
this group for the
2014-2020 period
debate will focus on a mechanism for
member states to participate
some countries have reservations about
whether an eu level fund covering all 27
nations is the best way to help and
differ over the form that the scheme
should take